taiwan's president has unveiled the
Island's first domestically made
submarine a second sub will be
commissioned if testing on the Prototype
is successful Taiwan has been under
pressure from Beijing to avoid ordering
submarines from other countries tensions
have been rising between China and the
self-governing island Beijing claims
Taiwan as part of its territory
ramad is a principal defense analyst
with James he joins us from Singapore
now thank you very much for being on Al
Jazeera I guess first of all can you
just give us an understanding or a bit
of an appreciation just how big a feat
this is from Taiwan
yeah I think what is remarkable about
the program that was revealed just now
was the fact that it was able to proceed
uh successfully in the first place uh
and as silently as it did so we know
that Taiwan was acquiring submarines uh
as far back as 2014
um but between then and the unveiling
ceremony that we saw just now by
President XI England very little details
of the submarine have actually been made
public so this is an important factor
yeah it suggests that Taiwan
um they have not only been able to
secure the supply chain the physical
supply chain required to build this
vessel but the Taiwanese have somehow
managed to attain the level of
operational secrecy that is needed for
such a complex undertaking so I think
the fact that this submarine exists as
silently as it did over the past few
years you know it saves a lot about the
Taiwanese military industrial complex
and how it has evolved over the last few
years we even the threat from China
right why do they need it though The
Straits is not particularly deep and the
U.S has a significant presence in the
area so why does Taiwan need its own
submarines
yes it's very much needed I think over
the past few years it has become very
apparent to Taiwanese defense planners
that are never blockade from China is
going to be a very real possibility in
the future so the thing with submarines
is that they elicit a very strong
response from adversaries because of the
nature of the equipment itself and what
it does to transform your operational
doctrines so as we know submarines are
generally hidden from view they are
silent and they are very difficult to
predict so the just knowing that they're
going to be submarines operating in the
water that you're about to sail in it
injects a certain level of uncertainty
into China's calculations in the Taiwan
Strait and I think this is what
Taiwanese defense planners are trying to
achieve if you were to look at over the
last few years the Chinese vessels they
have often still operated almost with
impunity in the Bashi Channel and in the
Formosa street so just knowing that
there will be something lurking
underneath you that's going to be a bit
more concerning for the Chinese they're
going to be rethinking their operations
and that's what I think the Taiwanese
different planners are trying to achieve
with this I know it's been shrouded in
secrecy but do we know its capabilities
what sort of Firepower does it actually
possess or is it just going to be mainly
used as a deterrent
yeah if you were to look at the launch
ceremony or the unveiling ceremony just
now Taiwan has strategically placed
banners and National emblems around the
most strategic parts of the submarine
including the torpedo cubes so the most
important capabilities at this point of
time still remain unknown but what I can
see from the launch ceremony that is a
fairly live submarine larger than what I
expected actually okay from from the
dimensions it displaces about 2 000 tons
which will make it one of the largest
boats to operate in the region so that's
what we know about the boat at this
point of time okay thank you so much we
really do appreciate it that's rizwan
Ramat principal defense analyst with
James thank you